et comme chaque lundi désormais notre
invité vient nous aider à décrypter la
séquence politique du week-end avant le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle française le 10 avril
bonjour Pascal Perrineau bonjour vous
êtes polytologue prof à Sciences Po
Paris on va donc revenir sur et bien
notamment cette abstention qui menace
scrutin sur cette règle de transparence
pour les parrainages c'est 500
signatures qui font des bas avec ton pas
certain candidats dit favoris de cette
déclaration de candidature d'Emmanuel
Macron qui se fait attendre on a eu
quelques infos quelques indiscrétions
ces derniers jours mais d'abord un
module du grand meeting qui s'est
déroulé ce week-end celui d'Éric Zemmour
au Mont-Saint-Michel meeting très mise
en scène savamment orchestré devant le
Mont-Saint-Michel qu'il a appelé le
rocher le plus célèbre de France au lieu
de notre mémoire nationale
et d'abord et d'abord à Nicolas Bay
exhibé comme un trophée c'est lui qui a
ouvert ce meeting Nicolas Bay exhiber
donc après après avoir été banni du
rassemblement national et récupérer donc
chez Éric Zemmour
cette question est-ce qu'il y a une
différence d'électorat entre
l'électorats d'Éric Zemmour et celui de
Marine Le Pen aujourd'hui oui il y a une
différence qui surtout une différence
sociologique
la dynamique d'Eric Zemmour est une
dynamique qui s'est nourrit avant tout
de couche moyenne
de petites et moyennes bourgeoisie et
quand vous regardez le profil d'Éric
Zemmour il a à peu près implanté de
manière égale avec une légère
sur-représentation chez les professions
indépendantes
il est à peu près implanté de manière
égale dans toutes les couches sociales
en revanche Marine Le Pen elle s'est
tout à fait autre chose
c'est une protestation sociale qui
cherche un exutoire politique c'est
autre chose qu'Eric Zemmour Eric Zemmour
est plus sur le terrain politique
stricto-sensu ou sur la nostalgie d'une
certaine France éternelle puissante etc
il a joué beaucoup sur ce terrain dans
son discours devant le Mont Saint-Michel
en revanche les scores pour l'instant
les intentions de votre déclaré des
ouvriers des employés des zones de la
France en difficulté pour Marine Le Pen
sont tout à fait impressionnants
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une protestation
essentiellement de couches sociales en
difficulté derrière Marine Le Pen c'est
une France populaire la France de Marine
Le Pen la France de d'Éric Zemmour c'est
une France qui est plus une France de la
protestation politique culturelle de
gens qui considèrent que la France ça
n'est plus que c'était la France n'est
plus comme avant c'était vraiment ça en
semi il a parlé de la puissance de la
France et de la répéter je serai une
bonne dizaine de fois notamment de
puissance militaire d'ailleurs on avait
du mal à comprendre dans quelle
direction il allait disant qu'il voulait
pas d'une France vassale ni des
États-Unis ni de l'Union européenne
d'une France qui n'aurait plus de
munition au bout de trois jours en cas
de conflits voilà c'était il cherche à
ressusciter si vous voulez un créneau
qui a toujours été populaire en France
depuis la fondation de la République qui
est si vous voulez le souvenir du
général de Gaulle mais enfin c'est pas
d'ailleurs mais tout le monde se
revendique aujourd'hui ce qui pose un
léger problème et ce qui doit perturber
le général de Gaulle s'il peut encore
percevoir ce qui se passe sur la scène
politique française parce que tout le
monde aujourd'hui dit qu'il voilà qu'il
a une fibre gaulliste tout à fait
impressionnante et ça fait partie si
vous voulez de toutes ces postures que
beaucoup de candidats prennent
aujourd'hui il reste à savoir si dans
les semaines qui viennent les Français
vont ne vont pas se poser la question
très bien vous affirmez tous ces
principes mais quels sont les moyens que
vous dégagez pour être à la hauteur de
ces ambitions et en particulier puisque
Eric Zemmour a beaucoup parlé des moyens
militaires il faut savoir que le retour
d'une politique de grande puissance
allez allons-y de grande puissance par
la France sur le terrain militaire ça
coûterait extrêmement cher et que pour
l'instant
l'armée française après une période qui
a été la période de l'intervention au
Mali est en train de se retirer de la
zone malienne et on voit bien les
difficultés non seulement politique
géostratégiques mais aussi matériel que
l'armée française peut rencontrer
lorsqu'elle se projette comme ça sur des
théâtre extérieurs
Éric Zemmour il fait partie de ces
candidats inquiets de ne pas obtenir
leur 500 signatures ça approche ses élus
pour pouvoir se présenter tout comme
Marine Le Pen Christiane tobira la date
limite pour le Conseil constitutionnel
c'est le 4 mars il reste une dizaine de
jours maintenant est-ce qu'il est
possible que des candidats dit majeurs
dans les sondages tiennent pas leur
signature à l'image derrière le passé ça
n'est jamais vraiment arrivé mais dans
le passé il y avait pas la transparence
du mode la dernière fois il y avait déjà
la transparence mais
là si vous voulez
n'importe qui ne peut pas se présenter
c'est pour ça pas que on a inventé ces
signatures d'élus locaux alors tant que
ces signatures étaient des signatures
anonymes c'était relativement facile
aujourd'hui les maires puisqu'il s'agit
essentiellement des mers se disent ah
bah voilà si je me prononce en faveur
d'Éric Zemmour peut-être que d'autres
dans ma communauté de communes ne vont
pas apprécier donc ils peuvent être oui
soumis à dépression vous avez vu
d'ailleurs que symboliquement c'est très
important le président de l'Association
des maires de France qui est un
républicain David Lisnard a apporté sa
signature à Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui est
vraiment pas de sa famille politique en
donnant un exemple pour les mères on
dirait écoutez vous n'avez pas besoin
d'être en phase idéologiquement
politiquement avec les maires mais aider
les avec les candidats pardon mais aider
les candidats qui pèsent un certain
poids Éric zemmourpez un certain poids
ou Christiane Taubira aidez-les à avoir
leur signature je crois que c'est un
très bon réflexe c'est un bon exemple
mais ça serait en effet ça poserait un
problème la pratique si un candidat
comme Éric Zemmour ou une candidate
comme Marine Le Pen ou Christian tobira
ne pouvait pas se présenter simplement
on ne peut pas laisser n'importe qui non
plus se présenter le paradoxe c'est que
des candidats qui pèsent très peu
aujourd'hui ont presque leur 500
signatures parmi les deux candidats
Trotski qui ne pèsent pas grand chose on
dit que Madame Natalie Arthaud est tout
proche d'avoir
des élus socialistes derrière et qu'en
revanche des candidats nouveaux par
exemple comme Eric Zemmour qui pèse aux
alentours de 14-15% des intentions de
vote ont du mal ils ont du mal mais il y
a aussi dramatisation à chaque fois je
ne les ai pas je ne les ai pas voilà on
crée l'événement c'est pas une
illustration de ce système est un peu
archaïque il faudrait il faut le faire
évoluer alors on pourrait imaginer un
mélange de soutien des élus et de
soutien des électeurs des signatures des
électeurs et je crois qu'après cette
séquence de l'élection 2022 il serait
raisonnable de faire évoluer le système
de parrainage sans le supprimer Emmanuel
Macron lui là c'est 500 signatures
officiellement il est toujours pas
candidat c'est un peu un secret de
polichinelle on a appris en tout cas ce
week-end de certains conseillers que
l'annonce aurait pu intervenir à la fin
de cette semaine au à l'occasion du
Salon de l'Agriculture samedi mais non
finalement la crise ukrainienne reballe
les cartes on est suspendu à ce qui se
joue là-bas dit certains proches du chef
de l'État où c'est vraiment une surprise
non il y aura pas de surprise on sait
qu'il est candidat mais il y a là aussi
un peu de dramatisation alors c'est vrai
que le président français est président
de l'Union européenne et qu'il veut se
donner encore un peu de marge
certainement pour son action c'est vrai
quand vous êtes candidat voilà vous
perdez un peu de votre statut symbolique
de chef de l'État le deuxièmement je
crois que le candidat Macron se dit j'ai
intérêt à rentrer le plus tard possible
parce que une fois que je vais être
objectivement candidat les coûts vont
commencer à pleuvoir et c'est normal
monsieur Macron deviendra l'homme du
passé on va revenir sur son mandat de 5
ans et vous savez comme on disait jadis
l'homme du passé peut-être un homme du
passif comment est-ce que vous analysez
le refus d'Emmanuel Macron débattre
avant le premier tour c'est encore un
symptôme d'une démocratie malade et
c'est une démocratie bancale cette
affaire parce que il est candidat il
sera un citoyen candidat c'était Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing qui disait ça en 80 80
il disait je ne suis pas président
candidat à partir moi je suis candidat
je suis un citoyen comme les autres qui
est candidat et on ne peut pas réclamer
un régime d'exception qui consiste à
dire et bien moi je laisse les autres
débattre mais moi je suis je joue
tellement dans une cour différente que
je ne débattrai pas je crois d'ailleurs
que cette attitude c'est les prolongé
jusqu'au bout suscitera une
incompréhension de la part des électeurs
les Français vous savez ils ont la
triple égalitaire ils ont la tripe
égalitaire pour les candidats aussi
ça peut être vu comme du mépris bien sûr
ça peut être dit comme du mépris or le
président Macron si vous voulez qu'il y
a par exemple une très bonne image sur
sa capacité à représenter la France à
l'étranger à un problème d'image c'est
la proximité avec les gens avec les
citoyens et là il renforcerait ce qui
est considéré comme un de ces défauts
majeurs et puis il y a aussi un problème
en ce moment au-delà des sondages c'est
l'indécision des Français et aujourd'hui
beaucoup de d'indécis
est-ce que ça veut dire encore quelque
chose les sondages aujourd'hui quand on
compte la marge d'erreur et cette
indécision qui est
l'idée d'un rapport de force mais les
sondages comme on le dit injuste titre
c'est une photographie à l'instant T
l'élection elle se tient en T plus un
t+2 ou t+3 et ça évoluera parce que
comme vous le dites les électeurs sont
volatils en revanche quand vous comparez
cette 11e élection aux 10 élections
précédentes sous la Cinquième République
il y a une caractéristique les Français
n'ont pas encore la tête à l'élection
pourquoi parce que
[Musique]
primaire même s'ils se sont très bien
passés et on l'a vu avec le Parti
socialiste et la candidature Hidalgo et
il n'embrayent plus sur la réalité c'est
parti donc de plus en plus cela offre un
débouché à des candidats apparemment
venus nulle part comme Éric Zemmour qui
est un peu un objet politique non
identifié mais comme les terres en 2017
Emmanuel Macron c'est d'ailleurs ce ne
sont plus des professionnels de la
politique
issus d'appareils partisans qui sont
projetés au premier plan c'est des gens
qui ont accumulé un capital de
popularité ailleurs
c'est un la société française devient de
plus en plus au plan politique une
société du spectacle merci beaucoup
merci Pascal Perrineau de nous avoir
éclairé sur ces questions alors que
cette élection approche à grands pas
prochain rendez-vous donc